last year all four nations of the united
kingdom
found their arrangements for awarding
grades
did not deliver what they needed with
the
impact felt painfully by students and
their parents
although exams are the fairest way we
have
of assessing what a student knows
the impact of this pandemic now means
that it is not possible
to have these exams this year i can
confirm that gcse's
a levels and as level exams will not go
ahead this summer
this year we're going to put our trust
in teachers
rather than algorithms
the department and of course had already
worked up a range of contingency options
while the details will need to be
fine-tuned in consultation with of
the exam boards and teaching
representative organizations
i can confirm now as i wish to use a
form of teacher assessed grades
with training and support provided to
ensure
these awarded fairly and consistently
across the country i know students and
staff
have worked hard to prepare for the
january exams and assessments
of vocational and technical
qualifications and we want to allow
schools and colleges to continue with
these assessments
where they judge it is right to do so
no college should feel pressured to
offer these
and we will ensure all students are able
to progress fairly
just as we will with vtqs in the summer